one of the reasons men are not honest to
women and women get continuously good
feedback from men is because those men
are trying to get laid there's strong
data on that it's called virtue
signaling and and actually and women and
men both virtue signal like for example
one study that I CED on the show before
is that when you have a fundraiser if
you have attractive women in the room
men submit more money to the fundraiser
because they want they want to show that
they're more altruistic so we show
higher levels of altruism when we're
trying to get laid this is why marriage
is good the reason I can be honest with
these women is I have no skin in the
game like I'm married I got four kids
yeah I can just tell them exact L what I
think because I'm not trying to get late